Et bien le bonjour c'est le début de ce premier jour à Kyoto c'est incroyable
Il est actuellement 6h et demie du matin et je vais aller au Fushimi inari-taisha
J'ai fait un effort pour le nom
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on y va aussi tôt
Parce que les touristes, ça se reproduit et ils viennent ils sont nombreux après
je suis explosé sa mère
J'suis explosé !!
mais ça faut le coup parce que la où on va c'est magnifique
C'est l'endroit, vous savez où il y a plein de toriis rouges plantés partout
mais que c'est beau Lucas ! Oh !!
arrêtez arrêtez on y est pas encore arrêtez
sauf que quand il y a un touriste devant chaque torii rouge
ça fait des portes de touristes
et ça, ça nous intéresse pas du tout
je propose de prendre un café et on y va
bon les amis je viens d'arriver et c'est extrêmement beau
waouh et voilà merci camion ça me fait plaisir, gâche mes plans
en fait c'est un sorte de sanctuaire où les gens viennent faire la prière
et le passage très très connu avec les toriis rouges c'est plus haut en fait
c'est une randonnée qui dure 2 heures
on se retrouve au torii où je vous donnerai des détails sur ce que c'est
voilà parce que je me suis renseigné, je me suis documenté oui
actuellement nous sommes au sommet du mont Inari
au tout début de l'année il y a environ 250 000 japonais qui viennent faire leur première prière ici
bon attention c'est incroyable gros buzz mon micro se débranche pendant que je parle
c'est incroyable, du coup je vais terminer mes explications en m'auto-doublant.
Allez c'est parti ! Donc ces toriis finalement c'est quoi ?
C'est des hommes d'affaires et des boites voilà qui les achètent
"Eh fils de pute " (Vilain skwizi) Et au dos de chaque torii se trouve
le prénom du business-man ou de la société qui l'a acheté.
et pour avoir ton torii ici selon l'emplacement
ça peut coûter jusqu'à 10 000 euros ! Donc lui là c'est genre
3000 euros et ceux autours c'est peut-être 5 euros, on sait pas !
*Rire pas du tout surjoué* Abonnez vous
Bon les amis petite surprise, en descendant de la montagne on est tombé sur un
café à chat, ce qui fait que je suis très heureux,
et actuellement y'a un Jumbo *lol*
Coucou Jumboooo
He béh ! (rire des employés et de la famille)
On en a aussi un ici, tout posé ! (Trop mignon )
Hooo *haha*
Bon ils (les chats) ont un délire avec mon micro parce qu'il est touffu,
et ils ont envie de croquer ou de lécher genre...
La queue de ce chat ressemble au micro,
c'est la même matière. Ho regardez comme ils sont mignons ceux-là !
Exceleeent ! Papa y'a quoi dans ton sac
Y'a du nutella, d'la cocaïne ? Y'a quoi ?
Qu'est-ce qui les attirent ? Ouais j'vous ai vus ouais, vous étiez en train de voler de la nourriture...
...Lâchez ce sac  on t'a vu
Héé, mais qu'y a t'il dans cette petite fente ?
Un chat qui regarde mal.
ohhh il est beauuu celui-là aussi ! ahhh ils ont défait ton vêtement...
Une réaction à chaud ? *Rire* -Non ils sont adorables...
Tu es apaisé, et tu me rends apaisé.
Hooo ça se fight
Hooo crochet du gauche.
Bien joué, une petite réaction à chaud du vainqueur ?
*Blanc* Parfait.
Les amis, je suis devant le Senju Sengendo,
Je parle pas très fort comme d'habitude parce que c'est de lieux sacrés, et il faut fermer sa gueule.
En gros c'est quoi, c'est une immeeense salle dans laquelle y'a mille UNE (1001) statues de la déesse boudique.
Et il y a du coups 100 rangées de 10 statues.
Le truc hyper frustrant c'est que c'est formellement interdit de prendre des photos ou de filmer à l'intérieur,
du coups, vu que je prend énormément de risques pour mes abonnés...
J'ai pas filmé, mais j'ai acheté un truc pour touristes à cinq euros,
et c'est juste une photo
Tadaaaa, et voilà *musique très épique et cool*
Et maintenant on va aller au Kiyomizu-dera (désolé.e pour la retranscription je suis pas sûr.e)
Nous venons de quitter Kiyomizu
car il y avait extrêmement beaucoup de... Monde !
Des gens partout !
Des touristes en kimonos qui se prennent pour des japonais
Des japonais en kimono qui se prenent pour des touristes.
*rire* on ne savait plus où se mettre
et du coup on va à Ponto-Cho le quartier.....
des putes! de l'époque,, nan parce que là les gens
ils croient que c'est vraiment... à l'époque c'était
le quartier des prostituées
C'est très très beau et euh surtout le soir quand le soleil se couche
Il y a plein de petites lanternes très très jolies
Très bien nous arrivons dans la rue Ponchoto... Ponto-Cho voilà
Même s'il fait jour les lanternes sont présentes hein !
Excusez-moi est ce que vous pouvez laisser passer le professionnel s'il vous plaît ? -Pardon excusez moi
Pardon hein excusez-moi, pardon
C'est donc une petite rue très étroite. *gloussements* Peut-tu me laisser tranquille s'il te plaît
Et ici il y a un maximum de petits restaurants
Et mais c'est une lanterne
La rue est très très grande et très très fine avec un max de lanternes. J'vais répéter ça 20 fois, j'ai que cette anecdote désolé.
Alors Ponto-Cho c'est une rue qui est dans le quartier de Gyon
Et Gyon c'est un quartier très très cool pourquoi ? Parce qu'on peut y croiser plein de Geisha et de Maiquo... Comme là-bas derrière... Et aussi des enfants courir et se blesser dangereusement
Mais tous ça Lucas c'est intéressant mais tu vas faire quoi dans ce quartier. Et bah moi je vous propose de faire de la balançoire
Moi j'ai envie mais j'attends qu'ils partent. *rire* Du coup je les regardent avec un regard menaçant depuis maintenant 30 minutes.
Bon clairement c'est une provocation de leur part ils veulent PAS nous filer la balançoire
Et bah nous on va les agresser carrément !
*Musique épique pour action ridicule*
*Musique épique*
Et ouais mon gars, tu touche plus jamais à notre Terre-Terre ok ?
Oh putain Florent, ça c'est une bataille de gangs qui commencent et ça va pas du tout. Les yakuzas sont venus en masse
Il faut qu'on fasse un truc Florent !
On peut pas laisser prendre notre territoire !
*musique épique*
Et voilà mon gars ! Pour tous ce qui hésitaient, qui voulaient prendre possession de notre Terre-Terre, et bah on est on est *BRLL BRLL* !!
je suis au Kinga Gucci
c'est le pavillon  d'or au japon en gros y'a juste un petit circuit à faire mais on peut pas rentrer dedans et c'est hyper décevant
Ca va les deux touristes? Comment voulez vous que je travail correctement avec une famille pareil?
Squeezie on est ton... Cassez vous cassez vous paparazies